esta Plaza de Santo Sofía en el centro
de kief es el lugar histórico donde se
celebra la Navidad en esta ciudad aquí
no solamente se levanta un árbol
navideño que el año pasado medía 31
metros sino que se llena de mercadillos
de comida y de objetos donde la gente
viene a pasear a encontrarse Y a
celebrar este espíritu navideño después
de muchas discusiones las autoridades
locales pensando si lo hacían o no este
año debido a la circunstancias
decidieron como lo anunció el alcalde
esta semana que sí van a celebrar pero
Una navidad mucho más austera han dicho
que aquí en el medio de la plaza van a
levantar un árbol artificial de 12
metros en la parte superior va a estar
el símbolo del ejército y va a estar
adornado con guirnaldas que van a estar
soportadas por una planta eléctrica para
no usar la poca electricidad que hay en
la ciudad en este momento ellos también
han dicho que saldrá de las arcas
públicas que tienen bastantes problemas
como el resto de la economía ucraniana y
que en este momento también están
destinadas a apoyar a la población que
no tiene electricidad agua pero
especialmente calefacción Ellos dicen
que todo está donado por la empresa
privada y que una vez se termine la
Navidad cuando pase esa noche de San
Nicolás entre el 18 y 19 de diciembre
cuando se entregan los regalos o el 24
de diciembre o El Siete de enero que es
la noche de los ortodoxos Ellos se van
le van a dar esta planta eléctrica a el
ejército y se van a a y todo va a volver
a la normalidad sin que nada haya salido
de la del dinero público y también han
dicho que esta planta eléctrica que
estará Aquí también servirá para que la
población pueda venir a cargar sus
móviles una imagen muy frecuente
alrededor de Ucrania en este momento
cuando gran parte de la población Vive
sin electricidad O al menos con cortes
que se extienden Entre 10 y 12 horas